using it as a new attacker white can't
trade queens that was your idea ivanka
it's going to take too long now to act
to get that into
into play yeah just underestimating the
danger
unbelievable scenes here because uh this
was my nightmare
when i looked at the position a few
moves again and i
okay so we do have a move he's advanced
his pawn so the i mean what's his
responsive
black word to just to push one square
further yeah we will see magnus push his
pawn one square further just to loosen
up
white's king shelter even more there we
go
yeah i mean this is we've said in the
past it is kind of alpha zero
influenced by ai and this type of idea
with black but it's just good chess it's
just pushing a pawn or weakening your
opponent's king
using the pawn as a battering ram now
wesley so takes the pawn but that pawn
looks irrelevant
white's queen is just not joining the
action we got an explosive move david we
have a tactic
on the board magnus is willing to
sacrifice
a knight just to open up
the white king position and it's going
to be checkmate oh
we have to show this mate yeah we will
go back and show this actually magnus
was ready to sacrifice his queen
um if something different had happened
there but okay wesley trying to trade
off a set of rooks but that's not gonna
help him
magnus pushing a pawn white's rook has
to move and then it's just gonna be
checkmate
wesley so he's either losing a rook or
he's getting checkmated he just resigns
wow what a dramatic start to the final